you're best known for being an actress
but now you're becoming an entrepreneur
and sort of a philanthropic entrepreneur
yeah so tell me about conscious Commerce
where did the idea come from there's a
really interesting movement happening
now in the world of philanthropy where
it is being removed from the world of
just the $10,000 a plate fundraiser
attendees the rich white people who
write checks this is how young
Millennials think of the word
philanthropy oh it's for older people
who can write big checks and they go to
fundraisers and they do need to pay for
organizations that I think is kind of an
antiquated view of what philanthropy is
there's this movement of for-profit
philanthropy which is spearheaded by
entrepreneurs like Blake Mycoskie from
TOMS shoes you know taking the idea of
educating the consumer by empowering
them to give back while shopping and
doing so by creating a product that they
would buy anyway and I think that's
really been a turning point companies
different brands coming up with products
that people are buying because they need
and want them not out of obligation to
sort of moralistic you know endeavour
it's not like god I really should buy
these TOMS shoes because I haven't done
anything this year to help the needy
it's not about that it's like oh those
are cute they were in vogue I want to
buy those and when I saw that happening
I thought okay there's this is a big
change and when you saw the rise of
Whole Foods for instance mm-hmm a
company that at its core has a manifesto
that's fighting against GMOs and
fighting for local organic ingredients
coming from local farmers but in the
form of a business that people are
attracted to because they just it's the
shiniest best product they want that
food it tastes the best it comes in the
best packaging so I thought that's
another example of almost tricking the
consumer into doing a good thing but
while you're doing that you are
educating them about how they have the
power to make the better choice for
themselves in the world so as I over the
past 10 years
learn more and more about the aid
community and had mentors from people
from Nicholas Kristof to Jeffrey Sachs
to Bono to different people running
organizations around the world I learned
more and more about the idea of dead aid
what wasn't working primarily from large
organizations and what was working from
the small locally run organizations I
thought we've got to find a way to tie
those smaller organizations to the big
brands that are making the most money
because the real money is in commerce
it's not in philanthropy each company
has a foundation account that foundation
is nothing that budget is nothing
compared to their marketing budget and I
thought we can really help these
companies promote their products while
tying them to nonprofits so we came up
with the idea of four conscious commerce
which is a company that pairs brands
with nonprofits